may is mental health month and it's a
subject that means a lot to us here at
cinemasins
in fact we're partnering with Mental
Health America to not only raise
awareness of mental health issues but
also raise a little money - we've got a
brand new cinemasins t-shirt in the shop
that all the profits from the sale of
the shirt will be donated to our friends
at ma check also if you'd like to learn
more about mental health you can check
out cinemasins comm slash mental health
awareness
we've got mental health screening tools
and detailed information about certain
behaviors that could indicate mental
illness mental health conditions are
real common and treatable we can help
reduce the burden of mental illness by
identifying symptoms and warning signs
early so check out these resources
Mental Health Month works because it's
about what others can do for us and what
we can do for ourselves
[Music]